comment entreprendre 10 illinois
éloignés de l'emploi sont accompagnés
gratuitement jusqu'au mois de juin par
la ruche de saint germain en laye pour
créer leur entreprise
le projet en fait c'est le programme qui
s'appelle le coup d'envoi car un
programme d'incubation nous accompagner
entre janvier et juin dix entrepreneurs
qui en neuf projets puisqu'il ya un
binôme l'idc les amener à structurer
leur projet a vraiment développé l'idée
qu'ils ont en tête de tester sur le
terrain
et puis voilà de vraiment pérenniser
leur projet à long terme sur le
territoire les entrepreneurs et les
projets sont très variés odile elle
souhaite créer des groupes de parole
pour les personnes ayant besoin d'un
thérapeute mais qui n'en n'ont pas les
moyens
être ensemble au sein d'une promotion
permet entre autres les change d'idée
par uche elle m'amène plein de choses
c'est à dire que par le travail la
solidarité qui a déjà entre les acteurs
de la ruche et les acteurs qui sont dans
la promotion coup d'envoi mais je veux
dire on neuf on bouillonne ensemble pour
avoir amené notre projet à terme
et tous les ateliers qui sont proposés
sont vraiment pertinent et soutenant ces
projets sont pour certains des
reconversions et pour d'autres un début
de carrière manaré capot de jeunes des
mureaux ont lancé une gamme de tisanes
local est artisanal à base d'orties et
ils ont une idée précise de leur projet
sur le long terme
on se crée devenir une marque de bharati
donne ou en fait on viendrait prendre le
café ou le matinal chez nous et en même
temps ont bénéficié d'ateliers comme des
séminaires des master class pour avoir
vraiment toutes les clés en main pour
s'approprier retrouver son pouvoir
d'agir à son tour puisque nous on veut
être fédérateur de cercle vertueux
le programme coup d'envoi est parrainée
cette année par frédéric avare directeur
des projets innovants paris ile de
france chez orange